[Music]
[Applause]
it's bringing Mike Florio pro football
talk live co-host and uh this is such an
important topic Mike joining us from
vacation to talk about this the last
vacation you're going to have until
after the Super Bowl all right let's
start with saquon Barkley the latest
report Giants offered 13 million he
wants 16 million can they settle
somewhere in between and this all goes
away one thing to remember Dan that
offer of 13 million was made before they
applied the franchise tag to saquon
Barkley what they wanted to do was get
him signed long-term and tag Daniel
Jones
when that didn't work they signed Daniel
Jones tag say Juan Barkley and pulled
their offer so back before the tag was
applied it was 16 I'm told that Barkley
wanted 13 that the Giants were offering
and neither number is unreasonable I
know Barkley claims it's all a lot I
mean it's not like it's 26 and 23 that
are out there these are realistic
numbers that he should want now the
question is what do the Giants do when
they know they have his rights for this
year at 10.1 and they could squat on him
next year at just a 20 raise total
payout of 22.22 million over two years
if they want to go year to year out of
the tag that's what the Giants have in
their pocket all Barkley has is the
threat to not show up yeah and the
problem is the deadline for doing a
long-term deal is Monday after Monday
they can't do a long-term deal that it
can only do a one-year deal so now is
the time for Barclay to huff and puff
because after Monday he's got no real
Leverage because he can't get a
long-term deal he's got leverage but
he's not using it for anything because
nothing he says or does will get him
that long-term contract after Monday
Now's the Time to make his play
Paulie has a suggestion on how we get
running backs paid
follow you that might be the judge yeah
okay Mike this is what I would want if I
were running backs in the NFL PA when
running backs are drafted out of college
especially first round running backs
their contract is three years not no
option for the fourth no fifth right now
it's four with an option for a fifth
which is very Team friendly like saquan
has had five years so their first
contract especially for first time
running backs is three years which gets
them to their second contract possibly
two years earlier makes them more
valuable and more likely to sign this is
what I'd want if I were running backs in
the NFL PA I think you're absolutely
right and look you can make the argument
the running backs should have their own
bargaining unit they shouldn't be part
of the NFL players Association they
should have their own separate thing
their own separate deal and that was
tried a few years ago it went nowhere
but you could make the argument that the
running back should be on their own
their own group an argument and a
suggestion that Chris Sims initially
threw out there several months ago and
I've been pushing it the idea that
that there should be a league-wide fund
that's available to pay running backs
early in their careers as they're
producing because the the best running
backs are are boom right away they're
automatic they're obvious they're great
and then by the time they're due to get
paid they've they've worn a lot of of
the the you know the rubber off the
tires and and teams are thinking we'll
just go draft another one so I'd like to
find a way to get guys paid as they earn
as they perform as they produce but
again you got to get the Union on board
you got to get the league on board
that's the biggest challenge getting the
powers that be to recognize it's an
issue that needs to be addressed and
hopefully they eventually will well we
brought this up a couple of years ago
that maybe we have quarterbacks who are
treated separate so it's separate cap
for your quarterback because that's
where all the money is going and then
therefore you have more resources to
spend on the rest of the team and then
maybe running backs do get compensated
but if a court quarterback's going to
make 50 or 60 million dollars then maybe
you don't have you know the Giants what
what they did with Daniel Jones is
idiotic in my opinion because they could
have gotten him for a whole lot less
didn't you know there was no leverage
there uh but I'm wondering if we could
do that a salary cap for quarterbacks
consider this
when the schedule comes out
all the great games are driven by the
quarterbacks and they completely
reshuffle the deck based upon as Tom
Brady retired as Tom Brady not retire
they admit that they did that in 2022.
he retired from the Buccaneers okay who
cares about Tampa Bay game so wait now
he's back we gotta Jam Tampa Bay games
into prime time it shows you how
valuable quarterbacks are not just to
their team but to the entire production
so if we're going to talk about
league-wide funds you know and this is
one of the ways they hold Patrick
Mahomes down and he's content with it
because he wants to win but Patrick
Mahomes is far more valuable than 45
million per year to the game not just to
the Chiefs but to the shield and to
every game they put on and all the money
they're bringing in the great
quarterbacks are always going to be
woefully underpaid and subsidize
everyone else in a salary cap system so
you're on to something but again the
League's got to be willing to do it the
Union's got to push it and good luck
getting either those things to happen
how does the NFL
I'm trying to figure out the best way to
describe this ask Force encourage the
Jets to be on Hard Knocks
well they came up with a rule 10 years
ago or so where you're exempt if you
have a first year head coach you have
been to the playoffs each of the last
two years and or if you've done Hard
Knocks the last 10 years so there were
four teams this year it fell into
category of teams that couldn't say no
the league decided collectively there
will be teams that can't say no this
year it was the Bears the Saints the
commanders and the Jets and the Jets
didn't want to do it I mean this is the
first time in the history of Hard Knocks
you're getting a team that didn't want
to do it and if you want reality TV
that's reality well can they can they
want to do it yeah can they that's what
I'd love to see if Hard Knocks is there
but they don't cooperate with Hard
Knocks
well and I think at some point they're
just gonna have to they're gonna have to
submit to it it's going to be harder to
fight it than to just acknowledge the
cameras are here and this is going to be
a distraction Dan I think the biggest
problem is this
whoever makes the decisions about what
the Jets are going to allow into the
final program had better be damned short
Aaron Rodgers is okay with anything
involving him because they may guess
wrong and then they got a problem with
Aaron Rodgers and the honeymoon is over
just like that I would want Rogers
sitting there watching the Final Cut and
giving me up or down on anything he
likes or doesn't like that's the only
way to avoid a problem and I think
that's one of the reasons they don't
want to do it because they could get
sideways with Aaron Rodgers remember
when they did the last time there was
that scene where
Antonio Cromartie couldn't remember the
names of his kids and and the Jets let
that go in I know I mean the the teams
we learned that years ago the teams have
final say over this well they better
exercise it in a way that doesn't offend
the delicate genius known as Aaron
Rodgers he's Mike Florio
Your Love Affair continues with Aaron
Rodgers pro football talk live co-host
and uh contributor NBC football night in
America summarize this ESPN expose on
Daniel Snyder and John Gruden and his
law John Gruden's lawsuit here
headline is that the release of the John
Gruden emails
was the first Domino that led to Daniel
Snyder being forced to sell but if
you're following the story carefully you
already knew that he was free and clear
it was over it was done the wrist slap
had been administered to Dan Snyder the
investigation report had been brushed
under the rug it was over when the
Gruden emails came out and he got forced
out of a job that dusted everything up
again Congress got involved and then one
thing leads to another in Snyder sells
the bigger issue is the John Gruden
lawsuit over who leaked the emails now
John Burton is not going to be a
sympathetic figure because he wrote the
emails and many will say he got what he
deserved but when you have a stack a
gigantic stack Dan a 650 000 emails and
a small handful of them get pulled out
and weaponized to take a guy out someone
decided we're going to take these emails
out of this stack we're going to give
them to the media and we know what's
going to happen Mark Davis is not going
to be able to continue to employ him
that's where this whole thing blows up
and this gets back to the fight every
time the NFL gets sued they try to pull
it into arbitration where they can keep
it all secret and they can stack the
deck in their favor and that's where
Gruden's cases still hung up more than a
year later is it going to be an open
court or is it going to be in the NFL's
private arbitration system and if it's
in open court John Gruden gets the
chance Dan to go all the way back down
the digital Rabbit Hole who ultimately
was the one that forwarded the email to
to the Wall Street Journal first the New
York Times second he's going to find out
and one of the quotes that really got my
attention in that story he wants to burn
the NFL's house down now that doesn't
mean the whole game he means the league
office he wants to take out Roger
Goodell he wants to take out Dan Snyder
if he can if it turns out Snyder was the
one that late the emails and Dan if
Snyder was the one he may he may have to
worry about a prosecution because he
under oath testified to Congress he
didn't do it if Gruden proves he did
there's going to be a perp walk there's
going to be a trial there can be
incarceration Mike this is better than
Hard Knocks yes
um who's more likely to get signed first
Alvin cook or D Hopkins
good question and anytime someone says
good question that means they're just
buying time to come up with an answer I
I think that it's probably going to be
Dalvin cook because I think cook sees
the benefit of getting into Camp early
and getting himself ready Hopkins is the
guy whose reputation is he doesn't like
to practice so why not wait two three
four weeks maybe somebody gets injured
maybe somebody ends up being not as
effective as they were supposed to be
because he's waiting for another team to
drive up the offer that the Titans and
the Patriots have made so I think it's
going to be cooked before Hopkins Andrew
Luck Hall of Famer question mark God no
I mean I know it's slow now
wait wait who brought this up
there's a there's an NFL rookie watch
Twitter account that just kind of
dropped it out that all his first six
seasons were insane and you know Hall of
Fame eligible in 2024. well we are too
but we ain't getting in and he ain't
getting in so I mean it just it's it's
his prerogative to walk away but do we
look at the quarterbacking position the
way we did the running back position
with Terrell Davis and Gail Sears well
but Terrell Davis won a Super Bowl and
get or two and Gail Sayers had rare
unprecedented Talent
the problem with the quarterback
position is there's so many great ones I
mean if Andrew Luck gets in Philip
Rivers is in it's a no-brainer Eli
Manning it's a no-brainer he's getting
in anyway because his last name's
Manning and he's got two Super Bowl wins
but you know you could look at aspects
of his career and say it's a closer call
than it should be but if Andrew Luck
gets in look at all the guys currently
playing who have a better case right now
than Andrew Luck so I don't think Andrew
Luck would want to get in I think he's
sufficiently self-aware to realize
that's part of the price of walking away
at the front end or smack dab in the
middle of your Prime he chose to not
play why would he expect I don't think
he'd ever expect to be in the Hall of
Fame he could still come back I guess
and put enough more years on paper to
get into the Hall of Fame but based on
what he did before he chose to retire
it's I think it's one thing to have and
he could say oh it was in his career was
shortened by injury and maybe it was
but still he chose to walk away when he
could have kept playing and and I don't
I don't know how you get rewarded with a
bronze bust for doing that and at that
position where it's about numbers I
don't know if you could have a scenario
could somebody create a body of work in
six years first six years that they got
injured and weren't able to play again
that the voters would look at that and
say you know what Hall of Fame worthy if
you win Super Bowls if you win Super
Bowls there there are people in the Hall
of Fame that wouldn't be in the Hall of
Fame but for their Super Bowl wins Lynn
Swann would not be in the Hall of Fame
but for his role with the Steelers four
Super Bowl teams and his performance in
Super Bowl 10 which showed us all the
way the wide receiver position could be
played if the ball is put in the air
more often and I'm sure that was part of
this process where we've seen the game
evolve toward the pass
yeah I'm wondering let's say Lamar
Jackson won two Super Bowls
and then his career ended he got injured
he's in it okay I think getting the
Super Bowls is in that's why Terrell
Davis made it the Super Bowl victories
put you on a higher level than than just
being great in the regular season
is Russell Wilson a Hall of Famer right
now
well no I mean
you could make the argument he's got a
better chance of getting in if he would
retire now than if he keeps playing
because as he keeps playing if he
struggles like he did last year that
drags him down and it makes it harder it
takes away from
the resume he'd already put together
Sherene Williams who's one of the Hall
of Fame voters made the point late in
Eli Manning's career he's running the
risk of hanging around so long it's
going to disqualify him from the Hall of
Fame because he's going to have too many
bad years on the back end of his good
years now I think Russell Wilson's got
the potential to be like Kurt Warner
Kurt Warner had that donut hole the the
year he was with the Giants and in his
final years with the Rams it dipped but
then he picked it up again but I still
think Russell Wilson's done enough
already to get there the question is
does he diminish himself with his play
this year and Beyond that's going to be
the real question I don't think that's a
great point I would keep him out of the
Hall of Fame just for the Subway
sandwich commercial
that's true you know the first time I
saw it Mike I thought somebody
accidentally aired something that
shouldn't have been on TV where he's
just chewing on a sandwich and talking
to you and I go this cannot be real I
thought it was a bit I thought it was
like some SNL thing where they got him
to do something that was supposed to be
funny it was so unintentionally
hilarious
Mike thanks for joining us from your
vacation good seeing you Dan all right
that's Mike Florio pro football talk
live co-host